la vie coûte cher écoutera encore plus
cher à compter d'aujourd'hui à commencer
par votre facture d'électricité
Hydro-Québec augmente son tarif
résidentiel de 3% pour la clientèle
d'affaires la hausse est établie à 6,5%
pour la classe moyenne c'est toujours de
plus en plus cher à cela s'ajoute une
hausse de la taxe fédérale sur l'alcool
c'est jamais plaisant alors on va
peut-être acheter moins on prend pas
souvent du vin donc
j'aurais marqué pas ce n'était pas vous
de me le dire j'aime mieux que ce soit
sur l'alcool que sur les tomates ces
taxe devait initialement augmenter de
plus de 6% mais elle a été plafonnée à
2%. une mesure annoncée dans le budget
freelance déposer cette semaine Québec
avait tout aussi agi en ce sens en
imposant une limite de 3% au mécanisme
d'indexation
ça aide à réduire le taux de l'IPC mais
évidemment c'est un impact sur le corps
financier du gouverne en même temps les
gouvernements du Québec comme du Canada
prévoit que l'inflation devrait retomber
possiblement d'ici 2024 les
gouvernements qui voient le
rassemblement monétaire de la Banque du
Canada
se disent on devrait pas contribuer à
l'augmentation de l'IPC
très raffiné dans les mesures ciblées
cette économiste et David le
gouvernement aurait pu adopter une autre
stratégie pour redonner aux
contribuables j'aurais préféré on laisse
la hausse la même pour tout le monde
mais que l'on offre des des crédits
d'impôts pour les ménages à faible
revenu et puis autre hausse à prévoir en
ce samedi celle de la taxe fédérale sur
le carbone qui passe de 50 dollars à 65
dollars laten une hausse du prix de
l'essence est à prévoir dans nombreuses
provinces ici qui me permettra au Canada
Montréal